each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so it's my great pleasure to
introduce hiring my quiz for visiting us
from stanford university together with
their advisor Christos Caracas and today
they are going to tell us about the
hardware based solution to high-level
semantic or security vulnerabilities so
go honey hey thanks for uh thanks for
coming here to hear our talk I'm Michael
Dalton along with a hard economic crisis
because the Rockets we working on this
research project we call raksha and our
goal is to prevent lots of security
vulnerabilities on unmodified binaries
using hardware support so I'm sure I you
don't have to tell you guys this but the
summer security is in a bit of a crisis
like this it's pretty well known and
established what we've seen recently are
that attackers are actually exploiting
an ever-widening trend or breadth of
vulnerabilities and software so you have
your traditional low-level memory
corruption vulnerabilities these are
things like your buffer overflows or
more recently or format string bugs and
you know they've definitely played key
roles in high-profile worms like slammer
and blaster and so forth but what we see
recently is you've actually seen a rise
in these high-level semantic
vulnerabilities that are actually
occurring in the secure languages like
Java or C sharp or PHP and so forth and
these are attacks like sequel injection
cross-site scripting and directory
traversal and these are these attacks
are actually increasing to the point
that they've actually overtaken
low-level memory corruption as the most
prevalently exploited kind of
vulnerability and the most frequently
reported kind of vulnerability and this
is really because you can export them
using only a web browser you don't need
to care about the underlying
architecture operating system of the
vulnerable hosts and they're actually
quite prevalent in practice so based on
these trends we're trying to find an
approach to security that's robust and
flexible in that we can actually handle
attacks at different layers of
abstraction using a single unifying
security technique practical and
end-to-end and that we can actually be
applied to unmodified binaries and
handle communication between the between
different executable objects because
lots of these vulnerabilities such as
sequel
action may involve say a web application
communicating with a web server
communicating with a database it's
important to be able to actually capture
that kind of information flow even
between processes in order to figure out
if an attack is actually underway and
finally we should be fast because if we
aren't faster when we'll just turn us
off anyway and not really done anyone
any good so the technique I'm here to
talk to you about today it's called
dynamic information flow tracking and
DIF dot paints information from
untrusted sources this can be done say
in the operating system when you receive
a network packet and so conceptually
speaking we add an extra tag bit for
every word or byte of memory and
registers and if this bit is set then
that memory or register value is
untrusted it's from a source that we
don't trust such as the internet and so
if it's not set then it contains normal
application data or code during program
execution we propagate this taint so
every instruction checks and if it has a
source operand that is tainted the
destination operand then also becomes
tainted this allows us to track the flow
of untrusted information at runtime so
at any point we know that if your taint
bit is set you're either untrusted
information or your derived from
untrusted information now that we know
this we can actually check for
suspicious uses of untrusted information
so what we do is for memory corruption
vulnerabilities we can have rules like
no tainted code execution this stops
code injection attacks or no tainted
pointed references which stops most
buffer overflows because you can't
actually corrupt a code or data pointer
to actually perform an attack or for
higher-level vulnerabilities we can say
things like no tainted sequel commands
which means if you look at your sequel
query and you parse it and you look at
the actual commands in the query the
attacker shouldn't be able to insert
commands into that query at all any
untrusted information just be flat data
and so the potential for depth that's
really compelling is that you can
actually protect unmodified binaries
from low-level and high-level threats so
I'm going to give you a memory
corruption example here so here's some
sample vulnerable C code this is a
fairly simple case where you take
untrusted information and you index into
an array with no bounds check
so here's the resulting assembly so for
instructions and we're gonna actually
show you how the taint propagates here
as we execute so on the right hand side
or yes left hand side depending on how
you're looking at this you know you can
you see you can see right now our tags
are all clear they're all you know the
tag bits are all clear because all these
registers initially are trusted and
we're going to actually go through this
program and show you how diff actually
halts this memory corruption
vulnerability so in the first
instruction we set the address of our
tainted input to register r1 which you
can see has no real effect on maintain
for the second instruction we load this
tainted information into r2 now because
this Kanan information is its taint been
set our two becomes tainted after the
load because we propagate paint and the
next instruction r4 is set to r2 plus r3
this will be the address of our store
now because r2 is tainted in the
previous instruction this taint
propagates to our for now we try to
store using our for we actually have a
security trap because you're not allowed
to dereference a tainted pointer and
this is actually how we would stop
memory corruption vulnerability before
any damage can be done taking a higher
level example i'm going to show you just
a simple vulnerable web form where you
enter a username and a password and your
goal of course is just to figure out you
know if the user is authenticated or not
so in this example some malicious user
is going to actually use this is
actually going to perform a sequel
injection attack so here's the actual
code passed the sequel query we're going
to select from a table where name equals
username this will give us a list of all
the entries that match a particular user
name so some malicious user whose name
starts with Christos has a inputted
their name is Christos and then they
actually end the quotation and then or
one equals one so if you actually paste
this into the sequel query and you know
actually see what you see what the
sequel database is going to be seeing at
runtime you'll notice that this queries
going to match everything because the or
one equals one is going to be parsed and
that's always going to be true so now
this malicious user has just forced all
users to be sent back by this table
so but if you look at the tags here you
can see the where name equals is going
to be of course you know trusted because
it's derived from application data so
it's it's no user input is influenced it
but the part supplied by the user the
Christo's or one equals one is going to
have its taint bit set but the problem
is that if you look at that or that's a
sequel command that's a sequel or
command and you should never have
tainted sequel commands which will cause
a security trap when we act we actually
check before the sequel database parts
of these queries we make sure that there
are no tainted sequel commands
beforehand and so in this example the
ore is tainted so clearly this is a
promising technique and so there happens
there's been some prior work and I'm
going to give you a brief overview of
what's been done so in software people
implement depth using dynamic binary
translation which allows them to
actually insert instructions at runtime
onto into running programs that are
unmodified binaries with no debugging
information now the advantage to this
approach is it works on existing
commodity hardware right now and also
your policies can be very flexible
because since this is all done in
software you can actually insert
effectively arbitrary code at arbitrary
places and runtime binaries which is a
very useful property but there are some
disadvantages or we would have just done
this in software the overhead is quite
high so it's at least 3 X 4 compute
intensive programs that are not I abound
and this doesn't work with some
real-world behavior that's really
important multithreading isn't handled
in a manner that's high performance and
safe there's a lot of race condition
type issues that can get involved and
you can ask me about that offline if you
want to hear more and self-modifying
code is also supported somewhat poorly
it also only works typically with the
single application so protecting
multiple applications or the operating
system is really hasn't been explored at
all and so far due to overheads people
only have chosen to attack to protect
against a single kind of attack and a
weak protection at that they've only
focused on control pointer based memory
corruption attacks as opposed to say all
in the recurrent more more strong forms
of memory corruption attacks or
addressing some of the higher the loner
abilities that we're interested in as
well
so harder support for deft has also been
done and prior work essentially you know
what you do with the hardware is you add
these tag bits so you actually
physically extend the registers and the
memory to support your taint bits and
then the actual instructions executed in
the CPU actually the CPU performs the
checks and propagation in parallel with
actually performing the usual data
operations so the benefit for this is
there's really negligible runtime
overhead the checks and propagation
happened in parallel with instruction
execution and since the memory and the
registers already extended with tag bits
there's no overhead with fetching them
and this also works safety with multi
threading and self-modifying code and
all the horrible behavior that you will
see and you know arbitrary binaries I'm
sure you're all familiar with that
Microsoft is you get the short end of
that stick occasionally from what I hear
but uh so the problem with the
approaches that we've seen are that
first of all they only have one policy
if they protect against low-level
attacks buffer overflows and the issue
here is that that policy is fixed into
silicon so if you have an issue with
that if that has a false positive in
application you're working with if it
has a false negative if attackers figure
out somewhat some flaw in it you're
stuck with what the policy that you have
and this is really selling this short
because you think dis can solve a wide
range of problems and by fixing a single
policy and hardware and saying that's it
you're really just I mean that's
incredibly inefficient in terms of
solving the kinds of problems that
people are encountering the real world
so to give you an outline of what this
talk is going to be how we're going to
truck sure this talk we're going to next
discuss our architecture give you an
overview of you know what's our approach
what are the salient features that
distinguish us from other work and we're
going to describe you the prototype
we've built where we actually have
real-world code running on an FPGA and
we're catching these bugs and then we're
going to go over the evaluation tell you
the experiments we've run and the
lessons we've learned actually applying
some of the policies that people have
been talking about to say apache running
on an actual you know an actual spark
cpu and we've actually found some some
of our results are interesting and it
turns out things that work in the
simulator don't work so well in practice
and finally we're going to conclude so
rachis philosophy is that we want the
best of both worlds software gives us
flexibility and the ability to make high
level analysis decisions like parsing
sequel grammars to make sure that the
queries don't have injected commands
and but hard riga's is fast checks and
propagation and the ability to work with
arbitrary binary behavior and we'd like
to really combine this so our goal is to
protect against high-level tax and
low-level attacks and also to provide
this protection concurrently so that
users don't have to choose do I want to
protect against sequel injection do I
want to protect its buffer overflows
that's that's a false choice you want to
protect us both and so we'd like to
provide a unified platform for actually
handling these vulnerabilities and we'd
also find like to be able protect the
operating system because operating
system older abilities are a severe
security threat and so we want to give
you a comprehensive evaluation we want
to be we will actually run unmodified
binaries that are real world Apache
postgres my sequel PHP on full system
prototypes so that you can actually
realistically evaluate this for real
world workloads because you know
oftentimes what happens in like the
simulators with toy programs doesn't
really reflect the kind of behavior
you're going to see when you look at
actual enterprise installations of aw
you know web servers and data base and
so forth now I'm going to go ahead and
transition over to Hari he's going to
give you an overview of our actual
architecture
thanks Mike so to build on what Mike
said we implemented this on a full
system prototype so let's look at the
changes that we had to make to a regular
traditional system stack in order to
implement our ideas so first of all as
far as the hardware is concerned we
needed to make a tag aware so we added
four bits for tag bits per word of state
in the system and what each tag but is
used to implement one security policy
now these four policies can be
independent of each other which means
that we could at a time have a maximum
of four security policies running
concurrently in addition we added
hardware support for performing
propagation and checks on these tags and
we get more we'll get into this a few
slides down the road and in the case
that we detect a security violation we
have support for user level security
traps which I'll talk about more in a
bit as far as the operating system
itself it needed to be made taga where
the changes that we had to be and we
change that we had to make were fairly
minimal less than a thousand lines of
code and Linux basically we just needed
to associate tag with data on context
switches so we need to make sure that we
save and restore them and also in cross
process information flow for example
through sockets you need to make sure
the tags transition along with data and
on top of this we added a new module
which we call the security manager and
this is in charge of setting the
security policies which are in turn
implemented by the hard work and this is
how we we garner our flexibility that
Mike spoke about because we can change
the security policies on the fly as we
need so these control the hardware
checks and propagates and in the case
where we do where we deem that for the
software analysis is necessary that is
performed within the security manager
now what this gives us is the ability to
run our ideas on unmodified binaries and
actually catch bugs quick you'll need to
assume the tackle we're about you
need to understand too many sis cause a
big apartment do you need to assume the
tech wear marks and stances cause you
don't need to understand sis ecology
just track the change because when we do
the software tracking we found that we
sometimes we lose the team propagation
because we don't understand Cisco and
some tension propagated you the cisco
and this is you do since a hardware and
use our volume in the OS you need to
assume the knowledge of cisco right so
in those cases we need to make sure that
the taint is associated with the data
because as you'll see further down
that's how we catch the the high-level
attacks such a sequel injection it's
through system columns position so we
need to make sure that the taint is
associated with the data as it as the
progress was there
okay so as Mike mentioned we built on a
full system prototype we took the Leon 3
which is an open-source spark v8
compliant processor which has seven
stages and we modified its RTL to
support our tag ideas so what does n
tail was adding support for tag bits in
all of state which included the register
files the caches and main memory in
addition we had to add a few modules
such as deciding what security policy to
apply on a given instruction actually
performing tag propagation and checking
the tag to see if there's an exception
and in the case of an exception actually
throwing it so as you can see over here
tags flow through the pipeline along
with the corresponding data there's no
change in the forwarding logic data
flows in parallel with the tags so there
is no significant source of any clock
frequency slow down now we we've adopted
a fairly simplistic approach where we
blindly sort of extend all of state with
just four bits registers and caches and
memory so this gives us a 12.5 percent
storage overhead this is what we used in
our first prototype but as you can
imagine there are smarter schemes that
we can make a whale of such as such as
the one which was introduced in this
paper from MIT the basic idea is this
that tags tend to have extremely high
spatial locality and we can exploit this
by by making use of the fact that more
than eighty to eighty-five percent of
all pages in typical workloads tend to
have the same tag so this makes a case
for a multi granular tag storage
approach where you could potentially
have page level tags and in the case
that a page doesn't have the same tag
throughout it you could introduce finer
grain tags such as cache line level tags
or even word level tags or even bite
level tags if if the case might be so
let's look at this illustration in this
case we have two pages in memory which
each have their page level tags and as
you can see there's this annotation in
the page table to indicate this now if a
certain page needs finer granular tags
we update the page table entry or the
TLB entry accordingly allocate a new
page in memory which is now in charge of
storing the tags for this page and also
update the caching so that the
corresponding tags are cached as opposed
to relying on the TLB or the page table
to provide the tags so let's look at how
we how we perform propagation and checks
on these tags so for each tag but we
have a pair of policy registers which
are set by the security manager which
determine how how these propagations and
checks are actually carried out now the
policy granularity is at an operation
type where an operation is defined as an
instruction class such as an arithmetic
logical operation or a branch
instruction etc now what this gives us
is the flexibility to select what input
operands we wish to check to see if
they're tainted what input operands we
wish to propagate pain to the output on
and also the way we wish to combine
these the teins of the source operands
be the logical and or illogical or now
the way we enforce this is by
decomposing all of the ISAs instructions
into one or more of these operations
which are as I mentioned previously
arithmetic operations logical operations
branches load stores comparisons etc now
what this does is it renders our
policies independent of the way these
instructions are packaged together in an
N and is a so this allows us to scale
from a RISC architecture on which we are
currently implemented to even something
complex like the x86 conceptually this
is extremely similar to x86 microcode
where complex sis constructions are
decomposed into a series of my crops so
let's look at an example as to how we
exactly set these propagate and check
policies so as you can see over here
there's a simple load instruction where
you load from a from the given address
now we can set different propagate
enables which basically determine how we
choose to propagate taint we can choose
to propagate only from the source
register we can just propagate only from
the source address all we can choose to
propagate from both sources and in this
case we can choose to either logically
or detains together or logically and the
teins together
using the same instruction a little
illustrate the way we enable our checks
so we can choose to see if the source
registers tag is tainted all we can
choose to see if the source address tag
is tainted or we can set both
simultaneously now let's look good this
policy is universally ugly sure sure
okay so this is something that perhaps
somebody with the knowledge such as the
system administrator might set before
running the application for applications
that are intensive on strings you might
want to enable address propagation along
with the source propagation itself
whereas for some other applications you
might not be interested in the source
data obtained itself but only on the
address taint so this is something which
is configurable and can be set by the
system administrator a priori you can
also envision a scheme where we have
sort of a learning module that figures
out what operations are being performed
constantly on the data and sets these
sets these policies accordingly
this allows you to figure out how
conservative or how optimistic you want
your process be as Mike said there are
some policies such as checking for
tainted code etc that you always want to
be on so in the case that a check
triggers or we fail a check we
transition to this security manager
module that I spoke to your little bit
that is folk about previously now this
is an oozer space why is it in user
space for two reasons basically first of
all this is allow this is to allow as a
fast switch to this module now if this
were in the operating system the switch
would entail a change in address space
which will which is extremely expensive
as you know because you have to flush
the TLB is in flux the caches etc but as
if this is in the same space as the
application all you need to do is incur
the cost of a function call it's
basically just a jump and you or the
maximum you have to do is flush your
pipeline and in addition since this is
outside the operating system this allows
our technique to scale so that we can
protect most of the operating system
code itself now what this needs is a new
operating mode which is orthogonal to a
conventional user kernel mode now as we
all know user and kernel mode differ Lou
in terms of the instructions they have
visibility over the address ranges and
the sort of memory they can access so
our toggle to this we introduce the
concept of a trusted mode where if
programs are the untrusted mode they
have no idea the tags exist tags are
transparent to them and if they're in
the trusted mode they have direct access
to these tag bits and to tag
instructions and this is how unmodified
binaries can run without any knowledge
of our tags so what we do on a security
trap to complete the picture is a switch
to this trusted mode and then jump to a
predefined address which is where our
reference monitor or the security
manager sits and this allows us to
maintain the maintain the user or kernel
mode of the application and not incur
the overhead of a natural space change
now I know some of you are wondering as
to the feasibility of this module
because you could envision malicious
user code overwriting the handler
answer is pretty simple we use one of
our tag bits to support a sign boxing
policy which ensures that our handlers
data and code are accessible only in the
trusted mode let's look at the following
illustration which should elucidate this
more so this is how memory is laid out
and as you can see in the handler code
and data we've enabled the sandboxing
policy so it's one of those tag bits are
set as opposed to the rest of memory so
code that exists in the trusted mode has
access to all of the handlers code and
data access to user code and data and
also access to tags that exist in user
space untrusted code on the other hand
can access only data that exists in user
space cannot access tags that exist in
user space and neither can it access any
code or data that belongs to the handler
and this is how we help protect the
handler from malicious user code so I
put it go ahead
that were basically trusted the corner
right so you I mean you might envision
some some user code even trying to read
the handler or try and write to the
handler just changing a pointer and
trying to read or write to that and
that's what we try and prevent from
happening that's your something like
sequel injection I'm being funny is that
what you really worry about bicycle
injection while you do your memories
right right guys your are gonna hire a
line right I mean because if we didn't
have this and you can easily envision a
buffer overflow perhaps / / writing the
handler and this is meant to protect
against that I just this also help to
stay out of the operating system because
otherwise you'd have to transition to
the OS which means that you can't extend
this mechanism to protect the operating
system as well what's the handle the car
gets corrupted and you track Oh what are
you trapped in it doesn't get corrupted
any axis triggers the truck okay because
it has attacked but said so essentially
it's like a read-modify-write that you
do on those and other drugs you can only
touch the code in the date of the
handler you you're the trusted otherwise
it's on the box so the security bits
themselves i'm using do some boxing
which is your protection mechanism for
the hunt so are you assuming you're
secure trap cannot cover every possible
attacks so you split to the code into a
translator and fast
because if resume you secure travel is
conservative you can't wrap everything
before the attack sure the Hendra then
going to differentiate to trust an
animal now because nobody knows her
attacker can manipulate a handler before
because you trap it right the handler
will check that all right not too sure I
completely on the channel you can hear
the non-violence you know if you have a
seat program and you do buffer overflow
and I do a store some cow into that
computer data I need some way of
catching so that's how but they're
listening so there's all about the
application that's not where untrusted
input is not influencing where it's
loading soy can easily I still o'clock
so like that's what one to put you it's
like you know where there can be a case
for spectators above the record progress
like an arbitrary copy but if they have
a corrupt a pointer yet we don't know
the proposed the products as far as
we're concerned the application just
copied data now not have a sonority
easily envision it like we can be
overwritten with safe change information
without actually you know what we
haven't called the bug ya and then also
there could be like you know a false
negative we only stopped eight imported
references so I mean you know if the
application is written and some like
them score horrible way we're like you
know you have like different like say
like they corrupted a flag used to like
a branch to do they don't actually
corrupt like you know a point of heaven
you know there are certainly case where
you can I mean this is just because it
essentially see is on time right if
there's you try to take out the ninety
percent and you know that's that's about
your mission
there's always one person order uses its
best to build offensive debt
so I was wondering about the experience
with these drop hammers to be primarily
sort of killed application well it
depends upon what you would like to do
in your in your module exam phones the
circumstances in which there's room for
performing recovery for instance on
setting song you know maybe there is a
good weight yeah so as as will be
talking about further down what we've
seen is in in low-level exploit such as
memory corruption typically programmers
tend to tend to perform bounced checks
or some sort of validation on code free
to help declare that it's safe and this
is something that can be done in this
security handler so it depends upon how
much you want to put in hardware as
opposed to kicking it out to software to
retain flexibility so that's the sort of
stuff that we kick out to the handler so
in those cases your continued you'd
continuously transition to the handler
to prevent to filter against false
positives and negatives right exactly
true look what has in some other
applications you might just wish to kill
it and if you extend this to say break
pointing our watch pointing because
these tags give you the ability to do so
in that case you just do whatever you
need to do and then transition back to
the application the hardware is dumb he
can trot fine-grained because then all
the analysis smarts policies its
software is this calm because you need
to be innocent mr. like an overflow for
example nothing on terms that what it is
the hot water goes across a script you
be just say otherwise across the
Caribbean tax office HTML and code all
the hdmi can spit it out I think this is
a sequel query so all this you know
quote all these commands so they won't
really the interface commands and pass
it through we have really explores two
modules you can definitely see the
higher level stuff it looks like there
is
recovery their husband else you end up
with a buffer overflow I think you I
don't think there's a great way to
recover safely I would just go pro
personally but you know with a high
level stuff I think he there is room for
recovery definitely you can just a
single quote the HTML or sequel go to
see what just happened there just a good
question for you talk about how how to
defeat cross-site scripting later yep
so an overview of our prototype system
we have a full-featured Linux
workstation which has been online since
sometime last year as far as the
hardware is concerned we're based on a
modified Leon 3 processor which is an
open-source Park v8 7 stage pipeline
single issue in order simple pipeline we
had to modify the RTL for the processor
and the system in order to support our
notion of tags and then we mapped it to
map & synthesizer to an FPGA board as
software is a gentoo based linux
distribution which is based on the 2.6
kernel which had to be modified to be
made tag aware as i told you earlier and
it can support the full breadth of
whatever gent who can do which is over
11,000 packages as far as the hardware
security policies themselves they are
set using pre-loaded shared libraries so
here's a picture of the board on which
we're running it's a xilinx university
program board xup vertex to probe
there's the fpga in there we run our
modified Leon 3 at 65 megahertz which
was the original speed of being on
blazing fast 512 megs of Duran and an
Ethernet NIC where we do it here over
Ethernet as you can see our overheads
were fairly minimal this is the space
overhead of our tag infrastructure it
was about seven percent more than the
existing one storage was twelve point
five percent and we have no discernible
overhead as far as clock frequency is
concerned as far as the way applications
perform checks and propagates of tags
are essentially free for us in our
scenario because these are done in
parallel with paddle with the data so we
don't see any slowdown because of this
our overhead is completely dependent
upon the software analysis that we
choose to perform which in turn depends
upon the frequency at which we
transition to the security manager and
the complexity of the security manager
so as far as high-level protection is
concerned we found that our overhead is
fairly negligible because we tend to get
lost in the noise of your system call as
far as low level protection itself well
we found that it's extremely dependent
upon the application for most of the
applications in the spec sweet what we
found is that they have extremely low
overhead whereas applications such as
busy or gzip which perform compression
on lots of user data which is tainted we
had a 33-percent overhead not to filter
false positives a negative
with our user level traps another
experiment that we performed was to
transition to the operating system to do
to perform the software analysis and we
found its overhead to be ginormous over
two hundred and eighty percent which
strengthens the case for user level
security Transpo next flick and now back
to Mike who will answer that question
exactly the bus is 32-bit with y right
so all buses are made products including
12 D Ram yes so what we did was suck was
the clever tricks that we use the neon 3
has both 32-bit on a 64-bit bus to do so
we essentially use the upper 32 bits to
store these types so in our prototype we
had to have the amount of memory that's
available because we use the top 4 vez
that's how we ensure a Thomas city
otherwise you'd have to do two separate
load restore its greatly simplify the
design I mean we don't actually need
32-bit tags on these four beds but i
mean this is this is just for a
prototype right get it off the ground
get it running but if you were act but
if you were to actually implement this
to do something fancier such as maintain
a separate page of memory that maintains
attacks this is because tags exhibit
significant spatial locality there's a
few check the MIT paper I mean it's like
something on the order like ninety
percent of tags or page granularity in
the address spaces that he was looking
at at least for the program for the
workload he had
I is saying like a yeah for bids for
each 32-bit in the memory and the
reality that could be like a dessert
it'll be two was from two different
sources the lower 60s ten in the upper
60s right right right creative positives
but it typically is not a problem for
buffer overflows because pointers are 32
bits but for string taining stuff for
you're looking at bike granularity
policies yes that can be a problem and
so we we have different ways of merging
tags you can specify how you want
immersion and or if you have a store
load that's less than 32 bits but in
reality i think we other thing we're
going to do is allow you you know
sometimes the near future i think we're
going to support first allowing you to
use the four bits to have one provide
policy because i think that for string
containing to have a lack of false
positives and negatives i think i'm by
policy tag is probably necessary at some
point or another now buffer overflows i
firmly believe 32 bits is fine so like
the make pointers or 32 bits and so if
you're interested protecting pointers
like there's no reason to go below word
granularity if you don't have too many
piece of data to firefighter and you
guys if you use a user level exception
yeah and put them in software so but now
if you use dolphins gonna be an over
yeah right so you essentially choose you
can virtualize provide tags or you can
try to support a hardware mode where you
use the you only have one policy but
it's per byte because we can also
support that very easily we have four
bits per 32-bit word we have four
policies we could have one policy per
byte what we showed no it's mike said we
just merge the text together right we
could what we could choose either
solution to virtualize or support i'll
provide policy if we wanted to like
handle that situation more efficiently
so Mike will lead on indeed okay so
let's go ahead and go over our
experiments really quickly so these are
all on modified spark binaries real
world programs pretty good spread of
utilities so we got you know networking
utility servers web applications search
engines that kind of thing and so we
protect against low-level memory
corruption so here you get your double
freeze your buffer overflows and a
format string bug and we also protect
against high-level attacks so we've got
you know directory traversal command
injection sequel injection across that
scripting and so the we actually the
first if d'architecture try to catch
acts without you know recompiling
applications requiring source code
requiring debugging information all
we've got are stripped binaries so it's
important to note here the protection
that we're using is actually independent
of the programming language as far as
we're concerned where the CPU we see
this stream of instructions and we just
pry information flow tracking to that at
runtime we don't know if the light of
the program is written in PHP C Java C++
what have you so we actually applying
the same programs to say gzip and wabbit
when we detect directory traversal bugs
even though they're written in
completely different source languages so
yeah as long as untrusted information is
involved in the computation causing the
integer overflow then yes I think of you
real real applications which use right
and we're gonna talk about how you have
to try to filter that dad that's a good
point so lots of real-world applications
do do this and then just a little stuff
so what they tend to think about this is
the string concatenation right one of
the parameters is tainted then so should
dissolve how does that play out at the
level of hardware can you
just Illustrated sure so if you're going
to concatenate strings what ends up
happening is you typically so are we
assuming at you're copying concatenated
or like you're allocating a new segment
of memory and then copy the two results
PHP da da well not only knows what they
do inside of the internals of PHP that I
so I think that you know what ends up
happening is you see a lot of bike
copies and word copies we like form the
new concatenated string and all of those
copies like propagate tain so the one
thing the one issue here with fidelity
is that we because you have per word
tags we tend to just like or or and the
tags together if you have like provide
copies but you know one of the things we
have seen is we have seen some limited
scenarios where you really do need bite
fidelity and so we're going to either
virtualize there or support a per bite
policy and so in either scenario what
you would have is that you know if you
can catenate strings together you end up
just copying you know the bites of your
second argument you know like past the
end of your first or you allocate a new
segment and copy you know like both
strings into that segment and in either
case you would just be copying tags
effectively because they'd flow along
with the data use directly over right
well now you just took eight plungers
and list this
physical copy right right that's what
you're saying so and I mean you know
right so where we check here is we
actually check the data Apache is
sending out to the client and we look to
see if the HTML there has painted HTML
scripts that are not allowed and so
that's what we do so you know however
you choose to store it you could have
triply indirect tables of like you know
data structures that are called by
forests of function pointer callbacks or
what have you like at the end of the day
you have to make this right system call
that's the floor with the stock of the
client and that's where we check we
check at the end we don't care how you
generate your data or what data
structures you use we just care is the
HTML apache ascending out is it tainted
or untainted I'll discuss that policy a
little more in the next slide actually
can get cebu kids sure so is it that
you're actually to clean the commands or
how do you think so your definition I
guess a potato chip Pokemon is if the
user input has something like our well
it's if the sequel if it's if the sequel
database would interpret it as a command
so you have to know the grammar the
sequel databases using you have to you
guys what I'm saying like it you can't
just say like you can't use or because
clearly users can have or their name or
like you know like people like people do
people couldn't very well you know log n
so it asked it has to be it something
that we know it be interpreted as a
command if you look at the structure of
the query so just to clarify the video
beso so the idea here is no you know
that the hand of the basis that doesn't
need to know everything about every
potential attack but you could imagine
basically that you know let's say for a
specifically the best product with
Microsoft one you know Marja gets a
module which says you know here's how to
parse SQL for the keys what course
includes an issue for us and we provide
you with information about what is
standing in there but you could imagine
you know different system vendors
providing different parsing you
riot what they've read the secret
structure sure i have a question today
to this is that I understand the
low-level taxing if I see at anything is
being pasta like a as a control flow
jump right then that will trigger this a
security crap but what I'm doing a stunt
is a force equals over how does secure
server tell this hard-working oh when
you see that condition come the other
way around no yeah so what we do is we
just say okay like we actually hook the
the system call when the database is
reading over the local socket and we
interpose and say before this data gets
passed to the database server I want to
make sure that the query that's about to
be passed to it is safe the database
server has no idea we're doing this we
know its grammar and we know where its
input sources are like we know it's
reading over a local socket or reading
over a reading its command reading its
queries from a file or what have you and
we know or reading maybe from a name
fifo on the file system we know where
it's getting its input from and we're
validating it before it gets to the
server the server has no idea where
there is pull some more jubilant so by
myself so that to me is a to see firstly
the any data input you will trigger the
handler to check if there is a passing
in it that's Korra second irresistible
yeah yeah but basically in a single
server receiver procurator you don't
know is your Curiosity browser does this
curry maintain an attendance data I
addict so it's a system mode yeah yeah
that me i don't know commands that are
just for everyone the second
he's gonna do this yeah i'm a mother
like okay okay yeah all right one more
so you have a group that being executed
he has you in descriptive this trust in
or is that we assume the script isn't
derived from user input to the web
server so what if it's from the fighting
system is fighting systems we are going
to look at trying to so right now the
user can choose what to trust we're
going to add support for tracking taint
across files so you can say okay you
took some user input and now you're
writing it to a file something to make
sure that we note that like bite range
like 256 to like 312 is tainted but like
right now we don't do that we're gonna
have support for it right now you just
choose do you trust this file or not
like you can just pick you can just set
your policy accordingly so if I did if I
had an attack by executed a legitimate
screw that was on the fight system but
something that I'm not about the name of
the script would come from you you'll be
calling exactly with a program name
being tainted and that's not allowed
okay so what's uh all right here we go
back to this actual slides okay so we
have four policies and I just want to
give you guys a brief overview of the
policies we're actually a rolling out
here so remember corruption a thousand
level view of this or thousand foot view
of this right so like we propagate on
all the normal operations arithmetic
load/store logical we check for two
things you don't you can't have obtained
a program counter 0 NE canada tainted
pointer and you also can't obtain it
code but i guess three things so we
actually untain 2004 manned this is
where things get sticky so the question
is like what's a bounced check and we're
going to talk about later how that turns
out to be a very ambiguous question and
so when we have something we think might
be a bounced check we kick it out the
software by using a security trap and
software analyzes it to see hey does
this look like a bath check if so i'll
do the untain and whatever we just let
the instruction executes as is okay
based on David data we allow that
control dependencies are okay they
connect her way to create know it's only
tainted by an indirect jump so long
story short too many branches happen on
legitimately happen on tainted data for
us to consider control dependencies and
you can't actually fully analyze control
dependencies without analyzing both
paths of a branch and you can't do that
in Hardware there's a good read the
rifle paper if you have questions right
if you want to learn about this there's
a paper it's called rifle it's at micro
2006 and they talk about all about like
the kinds of like nasty corner cases you
get if you want to do control
dependencies we don't do them because
you don't need them to stop active
attacks basically so second policy is
strength we're basically we're trying to
prevent for protect integrity not
privacy and so information leaks are not
our concern and integrity can protected
solely by considering data dependencies
in 99 percent of the cases so string
taining very similar propagate
everywhere no checks system call
interposition we just make sure that if
you're making certain system calls we
can interpose on them that's it and then
finally our last bit of the sandbox in
policy that Hari talked about we just
make sure you cannot read write or
execute anything with the sandboxing bit
set that's it and so sure when you say
you ignore those control jumps and
without cause any forced actives you
have
no I haven't seen anything in the
experiments now what you could well one
realistic scenario in which there is a
false negative is there's a humor to
crc32 SSH vulnerability where there's a
buffer overflow and openssh and one of
the ways you could exploit it was by
using that buffer overflow to clobber a
local variable that essentially was a
variable that said I am authenticated
and then at the end of the loop was this
thing that said if I am affinia cated
than just let the login happen and of
course they ordered it by saying you
know if you know like kirbo said I math
indicated set this to one and then if
you know so if you could clobber this
local variable SSH would just let you
log in now there's no pointer involved
here if you have a buffer overflow you
can just overwrite this integer and then
they branch on the integer and if that
you know clearly that that would allow
you to attack so that's it that's it
that's the sign of which this would work
but you could build software tools that
would figure out hey here's my address
space when this program is running this
variable is never tainted so you know
like if you ever branch on this variable
like kill the probe if you ever
branchless variable on its tainted kill
the program we could let you do that
with our infrastructure we just don't
have a policy that uses that because
right now we haven't been trying to like
do what an essence would be like you
know information flow profiling where
you would say like okay this application
never allow state to go here and like I
mean you can certainly envision someone
doing that and we could certainly do
that the thing is yes that well all
Harper has to do is busy see keep data I
vacillating anywhere based on right so
this is why I didn't do that this is why
I'm not advocating that policy because
the thing is emphasis change at runtime
and profiling is very difficult to do
for that I mean not just a heat like
what about like anything in mapped or
like you know I mean jetting for example
I mean that that's another I mean your
automation levels alone could call the
code very significantly I mean I think
that like profiling information flow is
a huge challenge and we haven't been
undertaking that cuz I don't think
though i don't think the reward is worth
the enormous cost of trying to overcome
those hurdles at this moment i think
it's the one percent case that's just
not compelling enough to warrant like
you know our investigation at this
moment
open SSL a reservation at an but even
even that is not a problem because if if
when you check the tenderness of a
pointer then the attacker has no way to
precisely corrupt right you have to get
really lucky so I mean it's
theoretically an issue but like in
practice it would be enormously painful
to get that to reliably work because
anytime you corrupt any point right we
do have we would detect it ok so we're
I'm gonna have to speed things up really
quickly because we're running out so
long story short high level bugs system
calls are a great place to check they
have complete mediation their language
and library independent and we get lost
in the noise really easily because
they're infrequent and expensive if you
can check it system calls check there
like that I mean there's certain
policies where you can't like format
string bugs but if at all possible
system calls are great place to
interpose fine grain propagation is
absolutely crucial so people can
catenate strings together and you need
to know if like this script tag is
malicious or not and that means you need
to know things that at least were
granularity and we found situations
whereby granularity is actually
necessary because of the way the manner
in which the application construct
strings for HTML we didn't need to
recognize gratification functions but we
don't we don't care how you try to
determine that you're not vulnerable to
sequel injection we actually just check
your query to make sure it's not
vulnerable ourselves at the last point
before it reaches the database we found
that to be a much safer solution in
general and finally cross process
information flow is pretty relevant here
web server database and web application
all communicating if you can't track the
information flow there you can't see the
bugs long story short memory corruption
of attack detection we've we've now
changed so prior work and shown that you
know trying to recognize bounced checks
might be a fruitful Avenue and we found
a lot of false positive issues there
because there's actually a great variety
of instructions used to do a bounced
check and the power to minus one so
forth and so on and not all bounced
checks are going to be comparisons and
we've actually found real world
scenarios in G lipsy and commonly used
functions where tainted input is used as
an array index without bounds checking
and it's safe because they only index
attainted bite and the array is 256
entries and there's no way to
distinguish that from a buffer overflow
from the hardware perspective without
debugging information that we just don't
have
so they're serious false positive issues
that can occur with this form of memory
corruption detection and the real
challenge here is can we find a way to
stop buffer overflows without relying on
recognizing input validation operations
like bounce checks and that's actually
some of our really interesting future
work that we're looking at and then I
mean this issue is not a diff problem
it's a problem of ambiguity if you don't
know what a bounced check is it's hard
to determine when a pointer dereference
is safe or not if it's going to have
untrusted information as part of it and
sorry I'm kind of rushing through but
we're about
yes that's true so oh well well uh I'm
sure you understood only meant though so
in conclusion we're a flexible dipped
architecture for software security and
catch high-level attacks we catch
low-level attacks and we can do it
concurrently and for future work we're
actually an also try to extend the
protection to the operating system
itself you know for our our salient
characteristics out of a robust we're
flexible you know we're extensible
through software software sets these
policies software mix of high-level
decisions and software handles the
corner cases that we don't want to burn
into hardware we're practical work with
any binary we're in the end you can even
applies to operating systems you can
applies to multiple programs they can be
communicating policies can cross
processes and so forth and we're also
pretty fast part where does all the
changing in checks and the actual calls
out the software quite inexpensive
because they're pretty much a function
call so giving you a quick overview of
future work and then I guess we'll be
out of time you know new new policy of
buffer overflow is clearly needed here
the problems that we saw where you will
see occasionally in applications like
gee let's see where you it's in biggest
as what a bounced check is we need to
have a policy that does not rely on
identifying bounced checks at all and
we've actually got something we think
might be workable in the next month
month and a half we're going to actually
throw that on to our fpga and give it a
whirl we're also looking at trying to
infer some policies for some of the
higher level stuff so you know directory
traversals are clearly relative to a
base directory command injection might
be limited to like say ok well it can be
a tainted file name for your script but
it has to be an Apache cgi-bin and we
should be learning that users shouldn't
be specifying that that should be
readily evident from system call traces
and so we're wondering there's some
low-hanging fruit there that would just
make it easier well or I could be
totally wrong so I guess we'll find out
it then seems to be nodding and saying
yes you are probably so I don't know
system security wise we want to pick the
operating system user colonel pointage
references and kernel buffer overflows
clear applications of dipped here and I
mean these are big problems and kernel
buffer overflows are pretty much the
worst thing we could possibly happen to
your system so if we can catch some
real-world versions of that that'd be
great and you know again as I mentioned
before cane across files would be pretty
sweet and so finally we also want to do
some real world tag granularity studies
how frequent our page level tags in
Apache how frequent are like tags at 32
byte granularity you know how often do
you really need provide
tags I mean no one's really sort of done
this for these big workloads and then
okay last minute beyond if we're looking
at some other work where we actually try
to do something much more aggressive and
that we cash opaque we cash software
functions on a page tags which actually
allows you much more flexibility and
what you are what you end up doing and
so we're essentially just memorizing
these functions and so forth and so are
motivating goal here is to take an
information flow aware operating system
called heist are developed at Stanford
by Nikolai Zeldovich and reduce their
TCB from about 15,000 line it's about
1500 and so that's that's our main goal
and there's other applications we're
considering to like dynamic translation
detailed profiling symbolic execution
simulation so forth and so on okay so
thank you for looking at this talk
listening to me speak and you know
carrying about rahkshi will be releasing
code very soon at rocks at stanford a TD
you it'll be fully open source the whole
stack will be releasing hardware
operating system and user space all of
it open source and so the board be
running on the sonics xgp three hundred
dollars for academics 1500 industrial
and everything is going to be open
source in the next couple of weeks so be
sure to stay tuned to the website and
yeah we'd love feedback from everyone so
please email us and tell us stuff we
care thank you
few minutes for questions if you have no
questions please go ahead without
anything for stuff like network stack
that pack is good that's definitely the
next thing we're gonna be looking at is
kernel level stuff we certainly couldn't
able the colonel right now we just have
we've just been focused on some of our
user space applications I'm really
interested in user Colonel pointed
references and kernel buffer overflows
in general just tremendous applications
there
so it wasn't completely clear what the
status was in terms of sort of
day-to-day you presumably you could have
us a web server running with this
running on it and all kinds of you know
applications using the tainting and etc
so is that is that the case I mean is it
is it is it debugged and all the false
positives taken care of so that it runs
normally 24-7 yes so we have we did find
Paul spawn the buffer overflow stuff
again with with respect to recognizing
bounced checks for data pointed
references if you want to leave on code
pointers in code injection I've never
seen a problem with that so I mean I
kedah I'm actually about to I'm actually
finishing up our gen to build right now
when I am finished I'm going to leave
code for nerds and code injection
production on for every program and just
see what happens I'm pretty confident
that we'll be fine because you know the
Minos paper and some of the other diff
works have done that in like Linux and
they've actually you know actually left
that on for every program in debian and
so i'm pretty certain that will work out
the new buffer overflow guy that we're
hoping to work on the next month I'm
gonna once i get that working with Hari
we're going to we're gonna actually loot
turn that on for every program and just
see what happens just like you know run
VI run apache you know like leave it on
for everything we do and just see I mean
that that's the only real way to be
certain that these policies are real
world right so we're certainly going to
be investigating about angle further and
you know of course and this is all hope
and everyone is free to like you know
run whatever the hell they feel I can
see what breaks and that's not mean
feedback is awesome right so we hope
that people actually do try that I mean
you know they will find out like you
know CBS 2 something wacky we never
thought of or something like that looks
like the policies you're considered so
far have this binary notion of last
night either something is trust an area
understood but what if i wanted to
specify some policies with partial
thickness like i have a plugin in apache
that's allowed to say free the right
result in damage opinion but not execute
commands for example oh you can do that
now because you can just say like you
determine when checks apply so so at the
boundary in which you determine that
something is partially trusted you would
just have two policies and you would set
one bit for trusted and one bit for
partially trusted and you would have
different check and propagate policies
for each one so we have four tag bits
and you can choose that one policy be
totally trusted one policy be somewhat
trusted one policy be mostly trusted and
like one policy be totally trusted but
that across product into action
I mean maybe a partially Justin Morgan
right to another partial interested
motive but not for full eater yeah we do
have the four bits be independent so
like you would have to figure that we'd
have to add some support there for like
having like multi-bit policies and so
forth and so on so right now we do have
four independent check and propagate
policies for the four bits so if you
wanted to handle some kind of per bit
interactions like bit bit three like
dominates bit too for its security
policy but like does not dominate but
one like you'd have to add I mean this
is all very very doable if you wanted to
extend the hardware interface some we
haven't really explored that too much
could be found it's just safer to say I
don't trust you and i'm just going to
validate you everywhere because that's a
lot safer than saying i partially trust
you so i'll just validate you in most
places but not these other places and so
from our perspective i'd rather just do
the Czechs everywhere just to be safe
and I mean if you want to do something
different like you can certainly extend
the harbor to do so without
fundamentally changing our architecture
in any way shape of form so my
understanding is another to detect
cross-site scripting you actually need
to build a kind of HTML parser right
side we haven't done we haven't actually
done intelligent HTML parsing yet for a
focus ugh you you are correct for to
really really catch XSS you really
should be doing like real parsing like
much more intelligible posture is
complete because it depends on the
Firefox or like versus my uverse
whatever it depends on the client
browser right yeah because javascript is
highly dynamic before us actually ask
you to the scripting you don't you don't
know the real meaning of this piece of
code well in general I well so I think
what the big rule we're looking for that
with our exes protections we're just
going to say like you know these are the
cities of the allowed it this is the
allowed HTML period and if you want to
like I don't think we're trying to
actually provide rules about like the
contain JavaScript code inside of the
HTML I mean I guess if someone wanted to
try that they could that it would be
really difficult because like you said
it's such a dynamic language I wouldn't
want to statically analyze javascript in
general these are some
neither the hardened on the operating
system know what application is really
doing this topic somebody with knowledge
of the application application developer
cares to kick in even if you don't have
javascript even you know not the love
you generated on them the app developer
has to be in poor dog with saying what's
illegal in this frame right like if
someone has to know like you know well I
mean even if you look at hi developers
can go do something right so you need to
look across at scripting like there's a
number of solutions available right now
like some like wikipedia has their own
XSS filter and livejournal as their own
exercise filter so like it's important
for us to be able two handles in
software because different people may
choose different filtering policies some
people may say okay you can use no HTML
element you say okay bold tags are okay
but without any attributes and like you
know like sigh everyone sort of has
their own solution xss like there's no
universally there's no Universal
cross-site scripting filter people use
right now which is why we're doing this
in software so that we can allow people
to say hey you know this is cross-site
scripting in my book and that is not and
like you know we let me let you know you
put this offer to let people choose
right at the end of the day and let like
people like domain experts make their
calls
okay thank you